AI um all sorts for us to talk about but
let's talk about turkey what are we
going to do to your home well obviously
it's a tragic events that have unfolded
overnight and we'll be offering um
assistance required and working with
other countries too to give the
insistence that they need so I I know
that cabinet colleagues will be looking
at this first thing this morning okay
what do you know about it so far well we
just know that there's obviously been a
an earthquake and there's been a number
of people who've been killed and are
missing and help is going into to
finding uh what support turkey needs at
this time India so we're hearing that
many hundreds of people have sadly lost
their lives we are blessed in this
country with not really being
particularly impacted by earthquakes
this area though very much is a lot of
the properties are not really up to the
challenges that you would expect to
withstand an earthquake we know that
some of the runways for airports have
been devastated
it's going to be tricky to help what do
we do immediately well it will be tricky
to help but I think if you look at the
help we've given other countries in
similar situations in the past we're
quite experienced in terms of getting
into places where say airports are down
and where access is difficult and we've
got a number of means of access in terms
of whether that's flying in support or
whether in the longer term getting
support in uh by sea as well but the
first uh priority is to make contact
with turkey which is being done to ask
them what help they need and to get them
the resources that will support them
over the coming hours and days okay and
that will have of course involve Medics
which brings me on to what's happening
here at home today Nurses and ambulance
worker striking again they say that they
have heard absolutely nothing from
Richie sunac
um or Steve Barclay how to resolve this
onpass well I'd slightly disagree with
them that they haven't been meeting with
the Secretary of State during January he
held almost weekly meetings with a range
at
I mean I take your point on pay before
Christmas that was not necessarily on
the gender but since Christmas
absolutely pay and working conditions
have been on the agenda we're very keen
to talk about forthcoming uh years pay
award in terms of us submitting evidence
as a government and the unions
submitting theirs and the slight
disappointment is we're in exactly the
same place as Scotland in wanting to
talk about the forthcoming pay award the
RCN have suspended strikes in Scotland
but not in England and what I would say
to Pat Cullen who I respect very much
and the RCN is if you if they've
suspended strikes in Scotland to discuss
the forthcoming pay award
um uh please could they uh suspend them
in England so we can get around the
table negotiate have a nice office than
England not in Scotland so in Scotland
they're just at the negotiation stage
about the forecast average seven and a
half percent payoff so so in Scotland
they put to the RCA members in Scotland
I think about 7.58 payoff for that was
rejected by the RCN members in Scotland
and that's why the strikes were ongoing
they have since the spend those on talks
on the the new pay award for this
forthcoming year we ask that the same
happens in England because every day a
strike action happens it does impact on
patients nurses have suggested or
certainly nursing leaders have suggested
if they're offered an extra three
percent on top of what they've been
offered now that they would look at that
which is exactly what they've been
offered in Wales so they've been offered
that in Wales it's not a full three
percent increase they've been offered
1.5 increase and a 1.5 lump sum which
would not be carried over in in
subsequent years
um that has to be put to members yet so
we don't know if the members in Wales
England's nurses expect that well we
have been pretty clear that we're not
going to to look at the current Year's
pay award that was agreed in April by
the unions and by the government and
accepted the pay recommendation in full
we really want to focus on the
forthcoming pay award as they're doing
in Scotland and record that which will
recognize a number of issues such as
inflation
um you know
Recruitment and Retention that that's
factored into the pay review bodies
recommendations England's nurses being
offered less than those in Scotland and
Wales they're not being offered less
than in Scotland so Scotland's at the
negotiations those in Wales oh we have
to take a responsible uh view about
everyone's uh uh so are they being
irresponsible in Wales I'm not you know
I'm not going to comment on the
negotiations in Wales they haven't been
agreed by RCN members it's been put to
the members and will know the result of
that in the forthcoming days members May
well reject that in Wales as they did
with an eight percent uh pay rise in
Scotland what I can say is that we are
we've got a responsibility to all
taxpayers in this country and we've got
a range of public sector workers asking
for pay increases
um and every one percent increase is
about 700 million pounds that we have to
find to pay for that and obviously we've
got covered backlogs we've got patients
waiting for routine procedures we've got
uh one of the busiest Winters we've ever
had with record levels of funding going
into the NHS to try and manage services
so um every percent of a pay increase
takes money away do you think that NHS
workers are putting lives at risk by
going straight I think it's a it's a
challenge you know obviously I'm I'm a
nurse and I've you know got I I am
asking you yeah so I campaigned when
there's a pay cap and a pay freeze um
when we had the lib Dem coalition
government so I'm for you know I know
how difficult it is to live on a nurse's
wage but also with ongoing strikes it's
not my question though with respect do
you think that NHS workers by going on
strike are putting lives there's a risk
to patients the longer strikes go on so
if you're cancel for your operation the
first time there's probably a minimal
risk that's canceled time and time again
because of ongoing strikes then patients
become more poorly and there's always a
risk and with ambulance strikes you know
if someone's not um got to if they're
having a heart attack or a stroke you
know that does increase someone's risk
the longer that response time is for
being a nurse is a vocation isn't it so
um putting someone's life at risk is
completely counter to what you go into
nursing for well I don't think any
nurses going on strike wanting to put
patients at risk and I know that it's
been a very hard decision for the
majority of nurses and that's why I say
to Pat as they are have done in Scotland
we're very happy to discuss the pay
award for the forthcoming year suspend
the strikes let's get back around the
table and see if we can resolve this for
patients as much as for staff okay it
doesn't look like it though does it
anytime soon well you know the door is
open Secretary of State's door is open
and we would welcome the RCN in
particular uh coming around the table
they have withdrawn from the Independent
pay review uh body process which is not
independent that's why well I would
disagree because there's been times
where we've not accepted the independent
pay review buddies recommendations in
Years Gone by and so if it wasn't
independent that would not be the case
we did accept it in full um this year
and the unions did as well and you know
that's the our method of getting a pay
settlement for the forthcoming year we
need to curtail our interview today I'm
sorry because of other events but thank
you very much indeed thank you